it's been 100 years since American women
got the vote almost 50 since they gained
access to abortions but as for getting
equal rights protection under the US
Constitution the clock is still ticking
why has it taken this long you know
[Music]
heidi shrek is a pulitzer nominated
playwright our bodies have just been
left out of this document from the
beginning her work what the Constitution
means to me tells the history of
domestic violence in her family I
believe that the women in my family
would not have needed to suffer the way
the proposed Equal Rights Amendment was
drafted in 1923 it took 50 years for its
language to clear Congress but it wasn't
ratified by two-thirds of US states
which is required by the Constitution
until the year 2020 in January Virginia
became the critical final state to
ratify the Equal Rights Amendment for
the women of Virginia and the women of
America the resolution has finally but
there was just one hitch the deadline
for state ratification had come and gone
in 1982 and the Trump administration
says that makes the proposed amendment
void Democrats and Congress are pushing
for its addition to the Constitution
regardless delays and distractions will
not slow our progress because there can
be no expiration date on equality this
is a clear message to the international
community that we embed in our
Constitution equal rights for women and
that there cannot be discrimination
based upon gender extending the deadline
for the Equal Rights Amendment would
also need approval in the
republican-controlled Senate where it
will likely face opposition personally
not a supporter some conservatives fear
it could lead to more abortion
or even outlaw separate sex bathrooms as
for heidi shrek the playwright she's
expecting twin girls in april i want
their future to look very different from
our past she says she hopes to soon show
her daughter's a US constitution that
guarantees their equality heidi Joe
Castro al Jazeera Washington